for real for real
this is a for realsies i'm gonna play so
different now
maybe everybody should introduce
themselves one at a time just so we can
make sure everyone's mics are working
hi i'm hacker also known as octoling
hacker what do i do
good question i'm jaden
here hello i'm booger uh mark say
something
hi markiplier youtube.com markiplier
subscribe for
great content today spend icy hi i'm
mortimer come to my doctor's office i'll
give you a free exam my name is aaron
i'm here
hey i'm alana youtube.com
today hi i'm dan my son loves this game
all right let's give 110 today oh really
seize the moment you're gonna tell me
right no
who are you i don't even know you what
are you doing tasks
uh what are you clicking right now
besides the kill button clicking the
follow you button yeah that's what i
thought
well you want to see how it's done or
how a pro does it okay
okay okay
[Music]
just walking in hey okay
yeah you should
doing my tasks putting things in a box
working hard or hardly working all right
see you around
lava is hot
[Music]
you almost got away with it
holy crap well a lot of those people
were just with you
are you really going to flip this on me
while i stood next to you and mark
at med bay that is true that is
true i double back because ross
and blue dan came from top of med bay i
went up to see if there's any bodies in
there and one of them is in fuel tank so
i think it's
both of them
i didn't really see susie around so if
anyone could vote for her that'd be
great
i was just doing my chores i'm the
reason you guys can breathe right now
is your chore killing people
i can't do chores if i'm the imposter
that's true they're not even called
chores
thank you um i do feel like it's
probably not spa dicey
it's but dicey
dan's alright who knows really whoever
that's ross and dad
i'm locking it in give me a million
dollars yeah
that'd be a killer combo well dan what
do you have to say for yourself
i got decontaminated a bunch of times i
don't know what function it serves but i
did it
and i feel very clean okay
wait so is shawn pushing it on ross and
dan yeah
he's pushing my biggest list is ross
because he followed up in a specimen
after us
the round was going super [ __ ] long
and i went to specimen assuming nobody
was in there because i was hoping to
find a body
and nothing to
oh it's definitely him then we got him
all right hey still one more though
mark did you vote yourself i meant to
vote for ross did i vote for myself
and then you sounded upset about
yourself
[Music]
i hate mondays don't don't get away from
me no
hey what's up man long time no see
hello who's that who is that i don't
know who was that who's that yes
it's dark i'm going to fix it i can't
see anything it's not fixing lights
i'm fixing lights okay good job mr
player thank you
okay someone's dead
ah my dad in here no one killed me
please
just you again this is me do you think
the ghosts are doing their tasks you
guys because this bar is very low
oh yeah wow that's that's during
meetings now
uh no idea
[Music]
who's in there who's in there who's in
there who's getting the shower
all right don't kill me listen just
don't kill me that's all i ask
don't kill me
whoa wait wait a minute that was
suspicious
that was suspicious
what are you doing over there where's
the button
help help
hey yeah
i've never pushed a button before i
never did
it i i was i
was more and more no no no no no no no
no no
i know where you're going with this no
i was just doing my chores like a good
girl it's not called chores they're
called
tasks i should have known the evidence
was there from the start
i went over to do what happened
wire which just so happened to be over a
hole and then i get to the hole and what
pops out of a hole
a witch's hat followed by a body
the hole was in front of the wire
wait did alana just leave the game it's
dan please get it anymore
vote for murder what the hell is
happening
you have to vote for him
i saw so much just all you got to do
no it's fine you got to vote they're not
tasks
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry well don't be sorry
oh no wait hang on a second
well how did you sad holy [ __ ] oh that
was a good one
that was something beautiful how do
you know what i did guys i went to
brooke and i was like hey brooke have
you seen the
the cams yet and she's like what i'm
like yeah just come down here and you'll
be able to see everyone and just as she
went down the camera
so her body went underneath the table it
was unreal my body was hidden it's so
smart
oh you can't hide the body sneaky i have
no idea play again i swear to god
mortimer like was in that room and then
appeared outside so i'm like oh yeah
definitely and i was like
no i don't know how susie teleported all
over the place i swear
i told you it was dead
i swear very strange
all right let's start up again proud of
you dan i'm really proud of you for
learning i was
so proud of a long way and i hate it
again no one will ever suspect you
you're just too nice
the most convincing imposter now we'll
always suspect him
i'm looking at my map thank you very
much what are you doing that seems fine
what are you doing what are you doing
maybe we should like do the buddy
systems we know no one gets killed
gotta go
uh hey guys aaron killed susie yo whoa
what hold on
oh no aaron that's definitely damn okay
oh no wait hold a bottle aaron
yes i was just walked up in there i was
heading to walk to reactor
he [ __ ] swiped her in i was just
going to the telescope
yeah well i saw more
my my wife my beautiful wife susie so
you just murdered yet
why would i do that all right i was
going to the telescope and i saw them
both in the same room and i didn't see
what happened but
there was a self-report i i guess
you didn't see what happened but it was
a self-report you murdered her that's so
weird why would i do that to my
beautiful wife
so technically he has to die now as well
i don't make up the marriage laws yeah
also there was like four of us at the
telescope
and then we all left yeah that is true
that is true so hacker alana and mark
didn't
not do this i just i've been with jaden
the whole time so
yeah yeah i mean to be clear i was in
the room when it happened which was why
it was so wild that i already did it
right
oh okay that's the more in front of you
not only was it his wife but he wanted
someone to watch
and he won't even vote for herself don't
even vote go down with honor
i don't want to vote i'm skipping vote
for your friend vote for the other
imposter
oh my god
hey i got a water jug anyone want to
watch me do
water jug i don't have hi mark
i'll be in your
all right run why are we running
john why are we running why are we
running
hello anyone hello hello
i don't know he went by running he went
i'll run away and then he just
people died when did that happen it
might um
okay i'm just trying to figure out how
to open doors
why were you running away from lights
and not to them when they were off
i was running to lights no no no you ran
away
that is true i went up fixed lightning
and would not kill anyone while we hung
out even though he was terrified
i am more questioned as to why you were
running screaming
because i thought it was you you ran
away from lights i went up and fixed
them no i went down
yes i was going down but you went
straight up screaming that jacksepticeye
scream and i went back up to follow you
and i was like why are you screaming and
then you were gone
oh my god mr spady and then i talked to
jaden
immediately afterwards and i was like
where's sean
i went away and then jaden's dead
where were you likely story
i fixed lights and then went straight to
button completely in the wrong areas of
our bodies is there is there a vent
that leads from near lights to the
office
i honestly don't know he definitely had
time to make that
because i had time to make it down to
weapons he he had time to make that okay
all right but i will say dodgy you've
been very quiet what's up with that i
don't know i've just got a dumb stick
around my forehead and i didn't know how
to open any doors
is that the doors you locked or the
other doors were the ones that you like
how do you lock doors
i don't think it's her i would like to
direct your attention again to the dumb
sticker
it is apt in this situation okay
what was yeah yeah the friends only
worked for dan for so long
[Laughter]
a lot dan what were you doing yeah that
was not a good play for you
no i dan dan and i were together a bunch
and nothing happened this is a problem
guys we should vote for someone one
thing is mark
for me what's the house just because i
have nothing else to go on
oh but if i'm wrong then we both look
stupid and that's bad yeah that's true
that's super true i guess we'll find out
oh gosh that was weak evidence at best
that was weak
actually i didn't even know lights were
on so i was just running around like an
idiot like i usually do
which is what i should have used as my
defense
can i have a bit of your banana to feed
my children
it's just appeal are you trying to
poison them you goddamn impostor well
it's very appealing to them
i have three tasks in the specimen room
please don't kill me anybody i don't
want to die
i'm just doing my test like a good
little oh my god
okay it's me i know
hello hello oh my god oh jesus christ
[Music]
jesus
i can say that i just confirmed uh aaron
via medbay scan and he confirmed me we
are accountable buddies yes we are going
to be
rolling together so please do not kill
us as as
dying next wait so then you we should
vote for you guys is what you're saying
no no that's not we were over at med bay
jaden can confirm that we were over
there
[ __ ] around for a long time oh so i
think i still have med base scan i
didn't get to finish
um i found a lot uh
i did not see anything though so i have
never talked about this i'm gonna go
make pee pee i'll be right back
okay that's so we should offer for help
no don't i know that was good no i
really need an accountability buddy
my children feel unsafe in this
environment i will say
that uh aaron and i hung out for a hot
minute and he did not kill me even
though there was nobody else around so
yeah there was definitely no one
else around i made a cool joke about her
mud that's true
yeah my sticker says mud sometimes yeah
it was very good
i feel close to aaron i will say that
bugs
bugs snacks or bugs sorry had a good
opportunity to kill me
down in um uh in the this the
the fossil put in the box room thing the
specimen yeah that's but didn't as i'm
alive
so it sounds like it's susie and dan no
no no no i walked past alana and she was
like what are you doing and i'm like
checking my map and she's like that's
fair and that was the last time i saw
her
if you were the last person to see her
no it's all because i was doing my
chores by myself
i'm gonna i'm gonna skip because i'm not
super super duper
yeah i'm gonna skip right now i'm not
sure yeah
oh i'm pretty sus on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all super i'll skip
dan dan what do you have to contribute
to the conversation
crew link broke oh no oh everybody hit
control r
okay no it's on his
don't you follow me susie was following
me
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
aaron why did you leave without me fool
don't you come near me
aaron you guys go
oh my god hello oh stay away from me
okay so you stay away from me
no my accountability
um out of respect for you aaron i would
like to let you know
that i heard ross screaming for you
thank you so much i was just tried it
was just me
aaron and susie and a trio just
constantly actually running into each
other
we didn't kill each other oh yeah no
yeah yeah okay sure yeah
i was trying to get aaron to let me come
with him because i was like you guys are
accountability buddies and i'm good too
and aaron was like no stay away
wait so what happened uh um
ross died and uh if bugs and the hacker
found him
okay so that's suspicious this could be
a self-report but also do where were you
um it was dark so i was trying to figure
out if i could walk
past the rocks to follow my destination
arrow and i could not and then a body
was found
i'm sorry that my my stories of where i
am
are always so exciting
as you play more you will learn and you
will become a better imposter like you
are right now
i can say that like aaron susie and i
were all dancing in the top right where
was the body found
um it was on top of the lights so
top left oh okay oh no the only other
one oh
no and no he couldn't take it
he's just so sad is the thing i mean
the other completely cleared a person
well [ __ ]
i don't think should we hit skip again
like oh what are the odds
hold on a second here wait we can't vote
on seven but we don't know we could we
could be safe if we skip
oh we're running out of time okay all
right okay
okay okay all right okay uh-oh dan
and we also can't hear dan at all yeah
dan's been red for me for
an age welcome to game grumps
[Music]
we are now game grumps all right okay oh
yes
yeah is definitely hacker
oh yeah oh this is definitely a hacker
why because i i you did
lights i went to do wires and then suzu
came in
you guys headed over to cams i saw cams
were on i did my
little like node switch i saw cams were
off and i was like someone said over
here and then
susie is dead no i left cams
well you also stabbed susie wha whoa
whoa whoa everyone slow
slow the roll here jayden i just saw you
past
me yeah over in met i was going into
medical area of the place over there
where was the body is on cams i went and
did
my wires in the cam's light area i saw
hacker and susie over there they went to
the left
exact path i went over to the lab to
switch the little mlg node i was like i
should check cams again because i think
someone is dead
and susie is dead on cam area
but i saw susie but i i did not do that
i saw susie i went down i did i went to
do my
task in o2 with the little truth thing
and then you reported why i it's not me
and if you vote me then i feel bad for
you because
that's it's not me and i feel bad i'm so
sorry
i am unconvinced but i'm willing to give
it a shot
[Music]
pain i only feel sadness
this is okay
well good game you guys
hey okay we're safe
have i proven my innocence to you guys
let's do it do it i got i gotta do it
so
so
[Music]
yay
[Music]
no no it's fine hey can everyone hear me
oh hey
we hear you oh thank god honestly mark
that was impressive
i we were all watching uganda off that
that walkway
it was great thank you all right so i'm
not an imposter just
either same huh at this point i would
love to be an imposter to be honest
what's up
hey guys how are you doing hey don't
trust you anymore
well you probably should that's fair but
also
i'm totally innocent yep
just well i guess they didn't die
and these machines
really broken
oh no
oh boo okay
you heard me i was like someone is on
camps i'm gonna see and i see
susie with a dead body under the table i
think
it was aaron it could have been ross
you reported ross this is the self
report
no it's not vote it's really not though
she's like
i screamed and she goes
[Laughter]
she was like walking by me as she
laughed at it that's like my normal
response i don't know
i had
yeah i came up with a ditty to hopefully
you know ward off attackers
so i genuinely don't know no no
yeah i mean okay yeah uh i don't know
how else to
prove my innocence she was just talking
to you guys he didn't kill you guys
i don't know how to prove it so
beautifully deadpan
i just don't know how to convince you
guys that i didn't
kill a guy i mean i mean
oh please guys don't oh god no
you're gonna break those oh you're gonna
feel real dumb
later not you it's jaden it's
i okay the commitment oh no i am dying
it is very sad that i am dead
god all right that was that was a
mistake i didn't mean to do that
oh my god so
so i think
[Laughter]
allow me to plead my case okay
i was thinking about other stuff and i
killed somebody
okay i voted for myself
[Laughter]
tidy game everyone great work great work
good impossible guys
pro plays everyone everyone did great
everyone did amazing wow guys so
so crisp so sleepy yeah
[Laughter]
hello
gonna do the good thing and blow up some
asteroids
yeah i'm also doing that dude oh yeah
are you
yep um real a lot of asteroids
ah man i'm up to like 14.
14 that's cool 18 20. yeah yeah yeah
pretty good
all right all right okay cool i believe
you i
i uh buy oh
well probably not alana ross jaden
haxer or me so we got we got some
confirms uh guys you want to share
oh yes yes please can it's pretty epic
so it's purple dark green and light blue
we're all yeah it's no big deal
we're just like confirmed to be
indecisive i see jayden and
hacker are all confirmed i sat there and
watched i didn't have med base gan but i
saw them all do it and confirm
it i'm green i'm three foot six 92
pounds hit me up
dude aaron aaron and i we were blowing
asteroids
he killed my high score destroyed me i
got
20. he got like 30 he was nuts no i
didn't i got 20. that's only how many
there are
never mind he got 20. i'm trying to
build you up here you know i'm trying to
build you i think
i appreciate
oh yeah i was doing water stuff
yeah um i was doing water stuff yeah
stuff okay i'm realizing i should really
have accountability she wasn't singing
her don't kill me song as she ran around
you weren't even near me true oh that's
so true
you should have been around us for a
year then
wait is dan still talking because i
still don't hear him yeah i don't hear
dan
dan you want to click crew link and then
hit ctrl and r
um all i'm saying is that everyone had
someone with them except dodger
hold on d dumb does that stand for
didn't you
murder yeah because i'm accusing
somebody else of
murder no it's due murder as in d you
murdered
stands for damn ulterior motives
get her out of here did unfortunately
murder
wow
darkness becomes me i'm also going to
the lights
i'm not doing it again okay okay
did fix lights together through the
power
no one's near me oh god i was gonna
finish
my tasks i was gonna be done
uh i went up to o2 by the tree hacker
was there too uh but she was down below
but there was aaron's body under the
tree
uh hacker how long were you in there not
long
was still was in that area uh because i
think's like we fixed
no we were fixing the lights i think
mock was the one who actually fixed the
lights
and then everyone kind of dissipated
yeah i just kind of matched my face
it happened so who is on the left
so i was coming down from the top from
security and i saw
uh aaron's body under the tree hacker
was in there as well
sorry hacker how long were you in there
not long at all
like i said as long as it takes for me
to go to the water
bottle and try to fill it up wait jaden
did that body happen
as you checked uh it was dead when i
saw it when i checked vitals wait you
saw a buddy as well
no i was on board i saw that oh you were
on vitals oh okay so this was like
more than four or five seconds ago
okay so it happened when you checked
vitals no it happened it already was
dead
oh okay it already was dead okay it's
interesting
mark i know whoa don't get me on this
because i was one task away from getting
everything done before i die and that's
never happened
i was one i literally opened the panel
i'm like yes yes and then body reported
so
i don't really know what's happening in
the wider world but i've avoided
everybody
to everyone who was on lights who went
where
afterwards i promise you that hacker saw
me
you walked left and down i walked up and
right and went straight over to mad bay
i'm currently in the tunnel heading to
specimen right now
where was mark in the doorway i was uh
i after lights i went straight down to
that little electrical coil thing and
then i went up to the
the panel this is the round where we all
cleared each other on maybe
hacksaw is clear on med bay again i'm
not supposed to be self-reporting yeah
no i'm not no i'm not suspicious of
hacker at all because at the beginning
that's why i'm saying how long was she
in there
i see it could have been a self-report
as well yeah i think
but actually no because it was already
dead for a while
anything um
kill me after i'm almost done i did it
i'm done i'm going home i'm all done
gang
i'm all done i did it stick stick
oh that sucks i was so happy too
wow wow what are the odds at least i got
my task done guys at least i got them
done
oh yeah yeah you guys doing you actually
got them all done yeah of course
no way no one suspects oh no they're
gonna get the
that was lovely that that double kill
was beautiful
dude i can't i can't believe the aussie
posse took us out man
oh well australians all let us
thought i rejoice though for the record
that that kill was
yeah i gotta say i gotta say the whole
roth's killing me and then stepping out
and then being like oh oh hacker i found
a body i thought a body
was i was like you [ __ ]
hey listen i got the moral victory and
that's all that matters to me
tasks done job finished
[Music]
oh